Alhamdulillah.
As-salatu was-salam
amma ba'd. A'udhu billahi min
ash-shaytani rajim. Bismillah ar-rahman
ar-rahim.
I welcome all of you with the Islamic
greeting as-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala be on all of you.
And I hope you had a good lunch.
And inshallah, we'll try and catch up
with the 45 minutes or 15 minutes that
we're behind schedule.
Now, we go to the next session, that is
the objectives of
the international Dawah training
program.
Hope all the participants have got these
notes.
And as mentioned to you in the rules and
regulations,
this is a point form note, where I have
given a serial number to each of the
objectives, so that if you want to know
from where
I'm reading,
you can go to that point directly.
Before I start every point, I will
mention the number. What you have to do
is pay attention more on me than read
the notes.
But if you want to jot some points,
so that you're with me,
I'll be mentioning the point number
before I start the point. So that if you
want to mention some examples or if
there are some details,
it'll be easier for us to be on the same
wavelength.
Point number one,
there are
five categories of Muslims as far as
the field of Dawah is concerned.
The first is Muslims
who never do Dawah.
Before
we go into the details, I assume
that
most of the participants are aware
what Dawah is. If not,
then you have to wait for the next day,
inshallah.
First category, Muslims who never do
Dawah.
The second category is Muslims who are
forced
to do Dawah due to circumstances.
Muslims who do Dawah when they're
criticized and attacked about their
religion.
The third category is Muslims
who do Dawah when the opportunity
arises.
For example, when someone asks questions
about Islam.
The fourth category
of Muslims as far as Dawah is concerned
are part-time da'is.
Those who look for opportunities to
deliver the message of Islam to
non-Muslims.
And the last category are full-time
da'is. Those whose mission of life is
Dawah
and are involved
on a full-time basis in conveying the
message of Islam. So basically, as far
as Dawah is concerned,
there are five categories.
Muslims who never do Dawah.
Muslims who are forced to do Dawah
when they're criticized. The third
category are also called as spare-time
da'is.
Spare-time da'is means when they ask
questions and they're forced to do
Dawah, so they do Dawah. Or only at the
leisure time.
The fourth category
is part-time da'is. And the fifth is a
full-time da'is. And
let me
tell you, what do I mean by full-time
da'is? If anyone says,
"I'm a full-time doctor
or a full-time engineer or a full-time
businessman or a full-time da'i." It
means
that most of his time
during the day is spent for that
activity.
Usually,
it is more than 75%.
Usually.
So, when you say you're a full-time
businessman, that means most of your
time
of the day,
if you work for x amount of number of
hours,
and normally
people spend about 8, 9 hours in the
office working for about 7
to 7 and 1/2 hours a day average.
They may spend about 8 to 9 hours. So if
you say you're a full-time businessman,
so you have to give about more than 8
hours a day
or at least more than 7 hours. If you
say you're a full-time da'i,
you should spend
more than 75% of your time
or
at least
7 to 8 hours a day
doing Dawah. This training program,
the previous one we had,
and
as many of you may be aware, that this
international Dawah training program
what we're conducting
in 2016
is after a span of
16 and 1/2 years.
Before that, I had conducted many
programs.
But me, personally,
as a full-time course, I'm conducting
after
16 and 1/2 years.
Last time I conducted
this training program 16 and 1/2 years
back in 1999.
In that program, too, the majority of
the participants were Malaysians.
And some of you have mentioned that
Brother Shakir was here. That time,
the course was meant for fourth and
fifth category. So if you see the old
notes,
fourth and fifth category, part-time and
full-time da'i. This course is
exclusively for full-time da'is.
Now, Abu Shariz always likes to be
unique and intelligent. He said in his
introduction that he's full-time
businessman and full-time da'i.
According to me, it's not possible
unless you're a half-baked
or a spare-time full-time or unless
you spend more than 16 hours a day.
And normally, my schedule, I spend about
17 hours a day in the office.
And
removing the time for salah, lunch
break, and all,
it is more than 14 hours. In that case,
if I had spent
maybe
8 hours
for one profession 8 hours for Dawah, I
could have called myself two in one.
But normally, when I mean by the word
full-time,
it doesn't mean 100%.
It can.
For example, if you say that 7 hours or
8 hours is pure Dawah, then on average,
I spend about 14 hours, so I'm double
full-time.
So when I mean full-time, it means that
the major time you spend in the day, the
major portion.
A normal person, human being, sleeps for
about 7 to 8 hours.
And he works for approximately, as I
said, pure 7 to 8 hours.
So if you say you're a full-time in one
particular profession,
then you have to spend at least 7 to 8
hours a day.
If you do anything below that, it can
either be a part-time or a spare-time.
I would like to know
some of you I'm aware of. From here,
I'm going to believe
that some are already full-time, some
would like to become full-time. I would
like to know that how many already are
spending more than 7, 8 hours a day
doing Dawah at present. Raise your hand.
1 2 3 4 5. Already spending 7 to 8
hours. Raise your hand, please. 1 2 3
4 5
5. So out of 19, we have five people who
already spending
more than 7 hours or major portion of
the time doing Dawah. And I would say
these people are actually full-time
da'is.
How many people intend
besides these five people, intend
after doing this course, if you're
studying,
it's understood that you're studying for
Dawah.
Suppose someone is going to university.
If it's Islamic university,
so it's understood that he's spending
part-time and gaining knowledge to
become a da'i. So he would come into the
future
case. Five out of 19. I would like to
know that from the balance 14, though
the interview was taken, how many intend
to be a full-time da'i after this
course. Raise your hand.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14. Masha
Allah. So that makes it 100%, so we're
on the same wavelength. This training
program is not meant for fourth
category. It was previously.
This training program, one of the
objectives, it's only for those
who would want to be full-time da'is.
The reason is that time I had more time,
now I have less time.
So we want to They cream, the best.
We want to have the creme de la creme,
you know, the best.
So that inshallah we are more effective.
So this training program is only meant
for those Muslims who are or would like
to be full-time dua. This course per se.
There are other objectives which I'll
come to later on.
Point number three.
This
dawah training program will not provide
you with all the knowledge required for
dawah.
Please
note this very clearly. Point number
three.
The reason we are going through the
objectives is that some people may have
come with a preconceived idea or notion
which most of it may be correct.
Some may be false.
Many people think that okay, once I do
this training class, after that I don't
require any knowledge.
For information, I'm yet a student
and will inshallah always remain a
student of knowledge.
La ilaha illallah.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun rasul Allah.
Arju ridhaka ya Allah.
>> Antar rahimu ya
>> Allah. Habni ataka ya Allah. Antal
karimu
wa minkal atawu ya Allah. Antal azimu ya
Allah. Fikal raja'u ya Allah. Antal
halimu
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulki
al-ghaffaru al-wahhabu al-mannanu
al-muta'ali.
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulki
al-ghaffaru al-wahhabu al-mannanu
al-muta'ali.
Ar-rahmanu as-sattaru malikul mulki
al-ghaffaru al-wahhabu al-mannanu
al-muta'ali.